mein lieber Herr Bandel wie lang kennen
wir uns jetzt schon 30 Sekunden genau
und ich habe sie gebeten hier
vorbeizuschauen weil ich gesehen hab
dass mein Vater ihnen nie so eine
Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung angetret
angeboten hat ich bin Schuhverkäufer und
das ist jetzt nicht Direktor
hochrisikobranche so schnell könen Sie
gar nicht schauen und es erwischt sie in
ihrem schulladen vielleicht war wirklich
besser mit Berufsunfähigkeit und wie das
besser wä safety first sch her ich hab
schon was vorbereitet men ich nur noch
da unter
unterschreiben auf ihre future High
Five ich überlege mir das noch mal mit
der
Berufsunfähigkeit ich glaub das ist
nichts für mich aber erner da ist
empfehlen